[Music]
but welcome back to the data science
hangout hope everyone's having a great
week
i'm super excited today because this is
my
friday
i'm going snowboarding tomorrow but um
hello to anybody that's joining for the
first time too it's great to meet you
i'm rachel and i'm the host of the data
science hangout
just kind of introduce this space if
it's your first time it's an open space
for the whole data science community
to connect and chat about data science
leadership
questions you're facing
what's going on in the world of data
science
so if you ever want to go back and
re-watch or share previous sessions
or share with someone who's missed it
it'll be recorded and shared to our
brand new data science hangout site
which we can share in the
chat window in just a second here
but we really want this to be a space
where everybody can participate and we
can hear from everyone so there's three
ways to ask questions you can jump in
live and raise your hand on zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
feel free to put a little star next to
the end of your question if you want me
to read it out loud if
you have a lot of background noise and
dogs are barking or something
but we also have a slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously too
and we'll share that there in the zoom
chat as well
we really love the dialogue that happens
live during these hangouts too
and if you find yourself really inspired
and have spoken a few times
maybe consider holding back a bit for
others to maybe jump into we want to try
and make this as inclusive as possible
and making room for others is also an
important aspect of that
and so just want to reiterate that we
love to hear from all of you no matter
your level of experience or area of work
as well
but with all of that
welcome i'm so excited to be joined by
my co-host for today theresa ward senior
manager of new glenn production at blue
origin
and teresa i'd love to maybe just start
off by having you introduce yourself and
a little bit about the work that you do
sure i'd love to
um so yeah so as rachel mentioned i'm a
senior manager in the program office for
new glenn
and um new glenn is our saturn 5 sized
roughly rocket that will put payloads
into space
into orbit and uh we're you know working
on jeff's vision for millions of people
living and working in space
um our particular rt my team
looks across the new glenn program
concerns itself with um
um you know how we operate how we
execute different our different program
processes but i also have the business
intelligence team so i'm responsible for
uh generating insight so that the new
glenn program can
make better decisions better better
decisions about
various things usually business problems
my background actually is aerospace
i worked for many many years
in
electromagnetic effects and lightning
protection of aircraft
and then went back to school for data
and so data is sort of my second career
um and so i've been doing data for maybe
three or four years now
awesome how did you decide to get into
into data
well you know as an engineer um and as a
fellow at boeing
you know working with data and trying to
tease insights from data to make better
decisions about the design of an
airplane was just part of the everyday
everyday job and so it was natural for
me to wanna you know maybe expand that
knowledge and and be able to use um
analytics and data science techniques um
in different ways you know outside of
engineering
so it was something i've always wanted
to do and i had an opportunity to go
back to school at night and did that and
um and so now i'm responsible for the bi
team um and blue origin new glenn
that's great and i think i saw on
linkedin that you're hiring
for yes
shameless plug
yes
so you you can find my linkedin profile
um my custom url is theresa ward 2
or you can look at teresa word blue
origin search i think i popped right up
on the only teresa board at blue
but we are hiring uh we're hiring
business intelligence analysts with some
experience um i've got a link there and
we're also hiring technical uh project
managers it's a very exciting place to
work
we're really stretching the boundaries
um and the
private space industry is very exciting
it's it's very fast-paced i really
encourage people to look at those
requisitions and apply and you can
always reach out to me too if you've got
questions
what do you look for when applied in
applicants
um so for our business intelligence
analysts um you know we're looking for
the requisite of skills you know a query
language experience you know sql
um
being able to code or be proficient in r
or python
uh we use a lot of tableau
um but
you know i i'm really looking for people
who are a good fit for blue and
blue operates um
in a way that um is more flat so there's
a lot of
um leading by influence um
you know um uh you know being able to
think outside the box i mean
honestly these are attributes and
candidates that everybody's looking for
um
but um it's no different for us right
looking for um
folks that can really help storytell so
it's not just enough to be able to maybe
this is a good segue into other topics
today
but it's not just enough to know the
mechanics of pulling data
writing scripts you know creating
dashboards maybe doing some predictive
analytics you have to be able to tell
the story
um you know we need people who are
curious about data you know at the end
of the day can look at the products that
they're creating um
is what they're creating makes sense
right does it really answer the business
problems we're trying to solve so it's a
it's it's not just the
requisite skills but it's also that
insight and soft skills that go with it
definitely i love that idea
or the term data storytelling and i'm
just curious how you
help teach people on your team how to
become better at that or
how or maybe some tips you have
on being able to do that
sure so
um i always point people i
i would imagine folks online are
familiar with um
um edward tufte folks might be inter you
know so edward tufte was
is um i still believe emeritus professor
yale
um he's one of the
grandfathers of you know being able to
communicate quantitative information and
intuitive ways
and he has a
um day or two course he's been doing it
for years and years
on you know intuitive displays of
quantitative information i highly
recommend edward tufte
um there's you know a proliferation of
coursera you know you know edx all these
different ways to
take classes in dashboard design
of course
you know user experience says you can
get a whole master's degree in that now
it's really about
um i think getting enough exposure to
some of those best practices you know
how do you minimize the ink to data
ratio
um
it's it's really i think um
uh going out and doing some research and
and a lot of that information is free
right you could go and um even the tufty
course i think is only three hundred
dollars or something along those lines
but it's worth it for me that that skill
is one of the most important skills and
i came from
um so if i go back in time a bit working
lightning protection of airplanes
you know it's a kind of a safety
critical skill for an aerospace company
and so you learn early that the way in
which you present information to the
chief engineer to the leadership team is
so important for making good decisions
or i should say smarter decisions um
about the design of the airplane
so it's driving that kind of discipline
i think sometimes in our storytelling
you know how can you really think about
um
how is the user really interpreting your
information another um not to belabor
this but another um
malcolm gladwell has a book called blink
i don't know if anyone's read that one
as well that's you know about snap snap
judgments
and oftentimes leadership teams don't
have a lot of time to absorb information
and so that makes it even more important
that the way in which we express our
data tells a story um so that's it's one
of my my big uh initiatives all the time
is is improving that for the team
definitely i see a lot of great um
recommendations in the chat window too
and we'll have to take that
write down that book blink too
so you said something earlier about work
you did before on lightning protection
for airplanes which just sounds
so interesting to me so i just wanted to
ask you a bit more about that too sure
some of the questions come in
um um yeah so just maybe a little bit a
little bit of background about what that
entails so yeah that would be great
right so um
airplanes are designed um to withstand
lightning attachment
um and so
if you ever watch a movie i can't
remember the last movie i watched where
it might have been um
the one with tom hanks where he's on the
desert you know he gets stranded
right um i think that was like a fedex
plane that got hit by lightning and but
but airplanes are are designed
to withstand that and so there's a lot
of protection measures that are taken um
with respect to bonding and grounding
and and and and um isolating components
sometimes emi emi emc emi protection
um at the box level so there's a lot
that goes into it but airplanes are
protected for lightning um
it's been an effort that's been going on
for decades all aerospace companies are
really familiar but not everyone
realizes that i think that there's a lot
of effort put into that
and some of the novel materials in
recent years have made it more
challenging but
it's a very exciting field to be in
that's cool so for for some of us who
are not familiar with some of the space
work that is going on what are some of
the projects that your team gets to work
on
sure so
our team supports the new glenn program
so um so that's the the rocket that's in
development right now and if you go to
blueorigin.com
there's a whole
section there on new glenn it's very
exciting blue origin is probably best
known to this point for new shepard so
new shepard
was a launch vehicle that took
william shatner to space
and there's a there's an amazon
um
documentary series i don't know if it's
a series
um
maybe one or two episodes uh called
shatner in space i don't know if anyone
has seen it um it's actually pretty good
uh but that kind of goes into the
you know the the the launch prep and
launch process and post process of
putting someone into space uh via new
shepard
my team on new glenn because we're the
program office we really support the
entire program so we might support
engineering we might support production
so the kinds of projects that my team
might work on are dashboards that
support those business processes
but it's an evolving program it's very
exciting yeah
cool thank you i i see nicholas you
asked a question earlier in the chat and
i'd love to have you jump in live if you
want to ask that
yeah
uh hey
hey teresa hi um
so i'm a
lead data scientist at higg where we do
sort of sustainability sas software
and um we also have a flat hierarchy and
i think that there's a sort of a
question of like how do you set the
appropriate structure and context for
people to operate effectively within a
flat hierarchy especially if they may
not be familiar with that sort of
corporate structure
yeah that's um that's an excellent
question
um
so
maybe without getting into too many
details here
um i think oftentimes it's really
helpful
to have some um
definition of you know as a
roles and responsibilities i think can
help
um with that right so
um oftentimes in a in a flat hierarchy
situation you're you may be put in the
room with the vp you're put in the room
with the ceo you don't know who your
audience is sometimes could be anybody
right so it's often times of high
visibility
um but in our flat hierarchy um it's
been really important to hire the right
people so i know that's not it's kind of
skirting the question of it um
but it's also knowing um
sort of the boundary conditions in which
you're working
so
being able to scope problems
understanding the business problems that
we're understanding the stakeholders you
know who who is the audience for the
insight that we're producing um i think
the process in which we're doing
um our analytics say using chris diem or
something
is important to it the whole process is
the influence right so it's not just one
aspect to it it's you know a
well-structured project knowing our
stakeholders having that open
communication with them has been super
helpful you know
and hiring the right people
sorry i mean you can't i mean when
you're in a flat organization it's it's
difficult to
you have to be able to think that way
you can't you know always lean on
others to
fight tough battles sometimes you have
to fight those battles yourself um
but if you work with good people who are
highly collaborative and are all aligned
to the same mission i think it's easier
i see someone had a follow-up question
to that in slido two and it was what
type of people work well in a flat
hierarchy
um well for us it's people who are
really flexible thinkers um
um i think it people who are highly
collaborative i mean i clap clap the
word collaborative is sort of overused
but
um
i think that they're the people that um
can exist in an organization where
there's some tension some some creative
tension
um and are comfortable with that
humility i think is really important
um actually humility might be the
biggest thing
i mean how do you
the the humility is important to stay
aligned to the mission as a team to work
together um
uh we need people who are willing to
build relationships right um with their
co-workers um
and in a professional way right um
uh around the work um so i think it's a
i think it's a mix i think it's a mix of
traits
that works well
um
yeah
definitely and trevor i'm just
monitoring the chat real quickly i see
you asked a question around hiring do
you want to jump in and ask that
hi hello guys
this i i think this
is really a very complex question
the
some things you can boil down to
algorithm some things are more human
so it's more about
sensing
um so so when when i see
i hear um
hiring the right people i always wonder
what that looks like so apart from
um someone being home as an example or
apart from that person being easy to
work with
understanding that they're in a flat
organization i wonder to what extent
culture
plays a role in that so if the person is
not
um if you are not from the same country
different teams different gender what
role does that play
in terms of
what is considered as the right
person hiring the right person oh my
question is clear
i think so
um let me let me give it a try
so um
and i might deviate a little bit from
the flat hierarchy piece of it but
my experience is that diversity
encouraging diversity in the workplace
is absolutely paramount
and let me give you an example of where
um different cultures and background
experiences have been actually actually
very vital to work so i i spent some
time working at um global good
and intellectual ventures laboratory as
a program manager
several years ago and i supported the
ebola vaccine trials
um and
the that work um
involved people from all all walks of
life you know you have people in the
field in sub-saharan africa
that we needed to rely on for
distribution of the vaccine
we had our academics our phds mds that
we were working with stateside
on some of the solutions
but that tension is always needed right
it's it's
the different backgrounds
um different professional experiences
together it's about that collision of
ideas and
um in fact this is a really good segue
too into how do you build communities
within your organization around the data
disciplines so when i was at boeing
i
co-founded the
one of the co-founders of the women in
data science organization at boeing
and you know how can we encourage
diversity in the data disciplines
um how can we support one another
um you know how do we
educate mentor
you know keep good employees you know
attrition is kind of an issue
so we want to retain people but it's
the diversity is what makes us better
and and without that um
and i think corporations are our
understanding that that's an absolutely
essential piece of of doing business
and so i i don't know i kind of i veered
off your question a little bit but it's
i think it's more than just the flat
hierarchy with respect to diversity it's
diversity is just so centered to how we
should do our work
okay so so i have a follow-up um maybe
statement
yeah so i mean i i've heard you yeah
good point and and clearly diversity i
mean many companies tell you that it
improves their bottom line big time
right because clearly you come up with
better ideas with different perspectives
right but in the hiring process
right especially in an organization that
is flat
where
hiring is not yet known to a science
right it's about what you sense from the
person
um you know how do you because humility
is not necessarily something that you
can put and measure with an algorithm
right so it's you in this interview
you're talking to the person you're um
feeding on the person right is is how to
know
is how how would i put it
is how to know that this person even if
they are from a different culture
right that they still have the traits
not just technical traits right the
technical traits to blend with the team
because your culture is different from
the person or do you know that
this person would be a good blend or a
good fit
sure
um well i'm i may not answer your
question and
satisfactory i'm not sure i will be able
to but i i because because my
i theresa you know operate a certain way
and um
i i theresa i have a lot of experience
with diverse employees um i've managed
very diverse teams and so
um i feel like i'm i'm somewhat
calibrated
you know
respecting cultural differences uh with
you know in in in context of a
prequisition or so i i'm afraid i'm
probably not gonna
uh answer it the way maybe you're
looking for but yeah i
yeah thank you though
thanks teresa
i love um hearing that you started that
community at boeing too and i'm just
curious is that something that you're
starting to do at blue origin you know i
knew enough here that um not yet but
quite possibly um
but that community
um
you know i not to veer off maybe into
this topic but you know there are
not the female population right the
ratio females to males very low in the
data disciplines more so than stem right
of the stem disciplines it's pretty
underrepresented
by women
and um and so our
our mission there really was to
um you know attract people to the data
disciplines uh mentor
um
um and and retain and um i i think it's
been it was we had community of practice
meetings we had um you know we had lunch
learn at lunch series
we did a lot around um
you know um
uh
you know
challenges right challenges in the
workplace i'm trying to think about like
you know
so we touched on different themes i
think that really hit it um hit a nerve
for people but we allowed we allowed a
space for dialogue and conversation
um i think just having a community
and just allowing a space for dialogue
and communication is huge you know it
could be even unstructured um
but just having that support is
important
thank you
libby i i see you had asked a question
earlier too and i just wanted to
turn the mic over to you if that's okay
sure yeah so my question was what mix of
people eating versus technical work do
you get to do as a senior manager and
how how did you know
that you were
interested in going into leadership as
opposed to being an individual
contributor oh that's a great question
well in my role so
management roles can differ widely i'm
sure a lot of folks on the phone
understand that
um
so um in some companies where you're in
a management role you're expected to
roll up your sleeves and actually do
some technical work um and the role i'm
in now it's a mix it's a blend
um when i was at boeing um
as a fellow certainly i was doing a lot
more technical work but
um you know there was an expectation of
leadership you know that you would
provide guidance to team so forth
um you know i think everybody has a
different way of
thinking about their career path and
what really
jazzes them
um for me um i really love working with
people
i'd love to be on a
on a smart team a great team where
people love working together and we're
working towards a common mission and
we're getting work done i mean there's
nothing better
so
sometimes i'm a contributor to that
sometimes i'm just i'm leading it or i i
i like i like removing roadblocks for
teams um you know there's that delegate
and disappear you know like
as a manager you know getting the team
to run run itself you know and so your
job is that roadblock remover i enjoy
that but i vacillate back and forth so
parts of my career i've been very
technical and i think being technical
helps you understand how to manage a
team that does that technical work
so i think it's really valuable to have
that technical background before you
become a manager in that area
um but for me my journey um has been a
bit of back and forth i'll do management
for a while sometimes i'll get bored or
i feel like you know i'm getting i'm
atrophying right i want to learn
something different and then i'll go
back to school or something different
then i'll get into the weeds again and
i'll become the manager it's kind of a
cyclical thing for me but um
but yeah i think along the way there
were times where
um i you know my my interests change
i've you know i've been a career
professional for a lot of years now
um and so the aging process for me
has also you know
contributed to
what i want to do
on a day-to-day basis and i think as
i've aged
um i i want to spend more time with
people so that's that's where i am
thanks so much
thank you teresa i like that you talk
about that as like a cyclical process
and
i think
we don't we that hasn't come up as much
on this like we talk about going into
leadership but never like going
back and forth
um rob i see you have your hand raised
you want to jump in
yeah i had a question uh sort of
on the topic of what we were talking
about with hiring and
flat hierarchies and um sort of
diversity and i think the the short of
my question is how do you encourage
people
within a flat organization or a team so
you know you're in your in from a
leadership point of view how do you
encourage people to
[Music]
feel encouraged and safe to speak up
when it is a flat organization and i
guess some context is like it's very
easy for me um
to speak up because you know for most of
my life i sort of
most of the people that i interact with
in a in a professional
capacity right they kind of look and and
smell and and feel
like me and same gender same race and
it's easy for me to um
speak up and as a leader how do you
encourage people that don't look and
feel and smell precisely uh you know
like you
sure
um
and i'll i'll talk more generally you
know not just blue or boeing or anywhere
else some
i think it's really important um
to
so i for me it's you know building trust
well there's a couple of things one is
the external environment
let me frame it this way there's the
internal environment in the external
environment
so the internal environment would be you
know my ability as a leader to build
trust in the team
um sometimes it's teasing out inputs
that i wouldn't get in a group setting
so sitting down with people one-on-one
to really understand what they're
thinking allowing some space some quiet
space in a conversation
trying not to fill every second
um and allowing team members to really
um feel it's a safe environment to
express their concerns or questions or
um and so i i try to do i try to do more
listening than speaking sometimes it's
easier said than done but
that's the intent
um but then there's the external
environment right an external
environment in a company i'm not talking
blue specific or boeing's i'm just in
general right
um i think some company cultures are are
more open culture um
making you know
maybe encouraging they want to encourage
people to you know maybe express safety
concerns or risks or
um and so you know but i've also worked
in places where
um you didn't feel as safe right to
express yourself
maybe to the leadership team so i think
it's a i think it's a blend right it's a
blend of
um the external environment in which
you're working and in the internal
environment internally you have a lot
more control especially as a manager
um externally as a manager you can help
manage that but
um you know the company and what you're
working for plays a big part in that
i love that point of
like listening more but leaving the
space for people to
to give that feedback and i think that's
something that's harder
sometimes remotely
like when we have one-on-ones through
zoom yeah
you know there's some i gotta tell you
there was um when i was in
um
taking some uh courses through stanford
professional studies um jeffrey pfeffer
who's a
i think he's still a professor um there
in the business school at stanford
um has this whole he has this whole
lecture about
um if you're in a technical discipline
and you're managing a technical team
and you're and you're talking the techie
talk all day you're clicking antennas
with people and you're using that left
side of your brain all the time all day
long that there's a need to actually
stop and pause
for a few minutes
before you have conversations with
employees or your team about hard
conversations right maybe
things that really need the right the
right side of your brain
to you know what i'm being i'm
generalizing right but you know
you need the soft skill part of your
brain to kick in
so there's psychologically goes into the
there's a there's an actual shift and
and there's a he actually recommends
people just take five minutes before
you're trying you're transitioning from
your technical discussions transitioning
to your people conversation i always
that always stuck with me
um and so i i try to do that
i love that that's awesome i i need to
do that too it's hard when you're like
running from a meeting to me it's really
hard yeah it's really really hard yeah
yeah
um ezra i i see there were a lot of
follow-up questions on like flat
hierarchy as well and and you had
one earlier would you want to jump in
and ask that
yes
excuse me yes i can um
there are a number of questions about
flat hierarchy and one of the things
that i was interested in knowing uh from
your perspective if there are
um if there are creative differences uh
within your organization about you know
person one wants to do it one way person
two wants to do it another way but it
but
it's flat
how do you determine which way to do
what which direction to go in
yeah i guess it's not when i say it's
flat
i'm not saying it's completely flat
right i mean there is
there is hierarchy it's just that
employees have an opportunity to
influence change at all levels
so
um
my job then would be to help
um
you know
uh
moderate right moderate conversations
that are um where maybe there's
constructive differences
um
you know you're always going to need
that you know despite what kind of
organizational structure you're in um
you know the ability to help build
relationships bring people together and
then sometimes there's um conflict
resolution um so i'm not yeah i may when
i talk about flat hierarchy
it might be a good idea for me to spend
a minute talking about what i meant by
that um which is you know we do have a
hierarchy but
um you know just what we have at other
companies but there there's an
opportunity though
where
um
we we leverage titles less right there's
there's less of a throwing around your
weight you know i'm such and such
manager
um therefore you will listen to me right
it's about how do you get work to done
through relationships
thank you teresa that's that's really
helpful
i see christy you had your your hand
raised maybe to add into this
conversation do you have another
question yeah no i just wanted to jump
off of what theresa said um
and and uh also maybe address the
question more directly with an idea that
i've seen work well in previous teams
but
particularly when in a flat group
and everybody has ideas and everybody is
incredibly curious and smart
um
of course you're going to have some
conflict with respect to um some people
want to do this some people want to do
that
i think it was beneficial that we were
on an experimentation team
um what what we did was we took that to
heart and
part of our culture was to embody an
experimentation mindset
so
when we came across a disagreement about
how
i feel like every retro conversation is
how we're gonna conduct retro um so you
know we we got to this point where it
was like okay well let's try this
doesn't mean we have to commit to it
forever let's take maybe a couple of
sprints we'll try it we'll come back
we'll discuss it in retro see if it's
you know measurably better or seemingly
better
and then make a decision based on our
experience
it's such it's really just like a very
low uh hanging fruit low-friction way to
just
move forward on something and not get
stuck there
and i think people
are receptive to it
sorry i you really hit a nerve with me i
love that
there's a book i don't know who wrote it
someone knows called the fifth
discipline
um have you guys read that
so it's about learning organizations you
know how do you build a learning
organization you know how how do you
build it how do you build a team and an
organization that experiments
you know that that's okay with failure
um failing fast failing early
how do you build that learning mindset
so that that really resonates with me
thanks for bringing that up christy yeah
sure and i i wish i could take credit
for it but um i'm i'm actually going to
plug um my very first hiring manager and
mentor and the person that i've learned
everything about culture
and maybe not everything but chris uh
chris j powers uh he has a website
online and you can you can look up a lot
of the talks that he he's given he does
a lot more software development talking
now but
very committed to team building
thanks christy could you put that on the
chat window too oh yeah of course that's
great
um
on this topic of
culture too there was an anonymous
question that was have you ever had the
experience as a leader to need to come
in and facilitate that turning around of
the culture
um i'm not maybe
i might need
so i might need to expand on that a bit
like i'm not sure so culture you mean
the corporate culture
or
maybe the culture of the team
maybe
um yeah actually um
both um or either i think would actually
be really helpful um just trying to
understand if you've ever
um
come into a a situation where maybe
there's been leadership shake-ups or
interruption is fuzzy and et cetera
any kind of anything that can really
take a hit to
team or corporate culture um how do you
how do you manage that either keeping it
positive
or um if if it's gone toxic how do you
recover
yeah
um
gosh um i've been in some situations
where there's been big shakeups i'm
talking agnostically company
agnostically right now um
and um
that's a really tough question because
oftentimes you're not a change agent in
those com in those situations right so
when there's been a big shakeup or
leadership change
you're just as much a victim sometimes
to those external forces as the people
who were removed or
um
but as far as things you can control
okay so if we were to distinguish the
things i can control from the things i
can't control
the things i can control are um you know
helping to manage morale on my team
you know um
i think a lot of that is keeping the
communications open i've been in
positions over the years where
um
uh we've had staff meetings and one of
the first things i've done in a staff
meeting is is talk rumors
right so you know
especially in a situation that's been
volatile or you know what are the what
are people hearing um almost like an
airing of grievances right sometimes is
necessary um because what happens that
the team sometimes needs a way to vent
what's happening around them sometimes
as a manager you are that only way in
which they vent
um so i found myself over the years and
that in that role but yeah yeah
the thing i can't control
is facilitating venting how's that
but what can we do to make it better
right yeah yeah no i think it's an
incredibly important role to take on as
a manager we need ics need that safe
space to be able to vent and know that
it's safe
right
right sure i see everyone saying
festivus
annual airing of grievances
javier i see you had asked a question in
the chat just a few minutes ago if you
want to jump in with that one
thanks rachel
and uh theresa i've been loving this
you know presentation in your comments
so oh
yeah no definitely uh so i'm just
curious um
if you're able to talk about it what are
some of the r or you know r studio
projects or workflows that your team is
working on are you
focused more on like
uh reporting automation or
you know statistical programming and
modeling
maybe web app development or is it a
little bit of all
yeah um i'm going to talk agnostically
yeah um
to maybe how my experience with our
studio has been over the years
um it's a little bit of everything you
just said
so
i've been on teams where we've used our
shiny um you know in lieu of tableau or
other solutions to to communicate to the
audience uh the insights that we're
generating um i personally used r over
the years um i've used it use used r a
lot for nlp nlp work
um in predictive analytics work um
so i i think i have seen our used in all
ways
um i've seen
our enthusiasts i've seen our haters
i've met i you know i think i i think
for me
i was i academically i was trained in r
and so i i gravitate towards r but there
i also know python and there are things
that i can do in r that i can't do in
python
um and vice versa and and um i i think
our uh wherever i've been r has been
used um either for reporting or helping
with reporting um or performing the
analytics that we need
i have to be general sorry
yeah no no that that's perfect that's
perfect i i just switched companies a
few months back and i'm
i believe this whole r programmer at
this company oh really you know i get a
lot of questions like why are you using
r and so
you know i for me what has really helped
has been just showing kind of
what you can do within the same language
within the same ecosystem like
you know
our markdown report knitted as an html
doc and deployed um
jarring on web slides or you know our
markdown websites or like you said shiny
apps like all these things when people
actually see the end results and if you
take the time to kind of
style your apps a little bit and make it
look really professional um
then people are like oh i didn't know
ark could do this
yeah oh yes i think a lot of it is
education you know
um
showing showing the possible the art of
the possible with r i think converts
people yeah
we were just on a meet up actually with
the
uh dutch institute of public health and
they said they did that exactly like
showing that prototype of what was
possible
uh there was a anonymous question that
was do you have advice for introverted
individuals and or people who don't have
as much privilege on teams where meeting
meetings are taken up by the same few
voices yeah
um yeah what a great question and i'm
introverted by nature so um
i've trained myself to be an extrovert
that's a whole other conversation uh
because sometimes corporate america
right rewards extroverts which i think
is also at the heart of this question of
it which is how do you
how how do you have a voice
when it's hard to have a voice
um
so
you know and it really depends on what's
happening so if you're
oftentimes i find that introverts you
know if you're doing good work and
you're producing results
a lot of that will speak for itself
if you're in situations where there's
you know personalities that dominate the
conversation
um
you know then sometimes the way around
that is is to have that one-on-one time
with the lead or the manager to make
sure that your voice is heard
um sometimes there's not a lot that can
be done you know i mean you lean that's
one of the reasons why you lean on your
lead or lean on your manager because
they have to make space for everybody
um
so i'm not i'm not sure that gets to the
heart of maybe what you're asking but
that's what comes to mind
seriously i haven't thought on that as
well but you don't mind sure
i'm exceptionally introverted and i know
a lot of my former colleagues in this
call will be surprised to hear that um i
think
it's
important to like find your voice and
just be comfortable speaking out which
is very very uncomfortable to do but it
gets a lot better with practice
so
find your way to just
speak out once do it twice do it three
times then it'll become comfortable and
habitual and hopefully you feel
comfortable with your colleagues to
actually speak out um it's uncomfortable
but
growth is uncomfortable
thank you josiah
i um i said christy you all right that i
saw arthy raise your hand or chrissy
raise your hand if you want to jump into
sure i was just gonna say also introvert
uh trained as an extrovert um through
many years of waiting tables um
and
you know i have to say that um
i think for me it's
it's
really easy for me to to speak up even
when i'm terrified because
um
i feel so compelled
to talk about the things that i care
about fiercely whether it's
equality um you know
standing up for injustice that i see in
the workplace
um you know just
mediating culture it's just all the
things that i care about
peaking at a b tests i'm gonna speak up
about these things because i care about
them a lot and so um i think that
you know find a thing that you care
about find a safe space and start
practicing what i did when i was
starting as a um as a new data scientist
was i used my team and i would test out
my crackpot ideas on them
and if they didn't laugh at me then i
would maybe talk to a leader that i felt
comfortable with and if they didn't
laugh at me then maybe i knew i was on
to something and i also had kind of
employed some squeeze methods so
you know i think there's a lot of
different ways to go about it but i
think the most important thing is find
yourself a mentor
and if you don't know how to find a
mentor uh reach out to me on linkedin
and i'll help find you a mentor um
it's just it's really really critical um
because
if your ideas are sitting in your head
they can't do anything
advice
i'm curious to
everyone if like having a way to ask
anonymous questions ask like helps with
that
because sometimes i think like
internally at our studio when we can ask
an anonymous question
if someone's like oh that's a great
question it kind of validates
me and then i feel more comfortable to
ask it
with my name next time
and i'm just curious if other people
have had that experience
i think that's 100 accurate having the
ability to ask a question anonymously
especially in a larger setting if you're
more introverted it's super helpful
we have town halls at our at our company
and um they've been all virtual
and
we've gone on for an hour and a half of
q a because all the questions are
anonymous and the ceo ceo takes the time
and he answers everything wow
and and it's
he loves it because it's interesting
because he likes to you know talk and
explain and everything else but
i mean you you get every form of
question when it's virtual and and when
it's when it's virtual and anonymous
um and
you know there's no fear at all if
people ask some pretty severe stuff
but you know what that's what it's for
um you know if you're gonna have a q a
and you're gonna
um as a leader you're gonna keep people
in the loop then you gotta be able to
answer the hard ones as well as the
softballs
thanks brian
probably i saw you were gonna jump in
before too
yeah so i um
i wanted to talk about the previous
topic this introvert extrovert thing um
that's a you know as a as a manager and
a people leader
um i feel i have a big role to play
to enable the extroverts and the
introverts in my team
creating safe spaces for them
and even the people who are in you know
who are introverted
when you
give them the right opportunity in
topics
um that they are passionate about and
they excel in and you create that
opportunity um
for that you know topic and or meeting
they will exhibit extroverted
uh characteristic traits um it's pulling
them out a little bit making them
comfortable
in their own space in their own skin
and i truly believe that as a manager
that's part of my responsibility
now going to the second thing that brian
talked about anonymous questions and in
town halls brian i'm glad you're ceo and
leadership team take that time and
effort to answer all the hard questions
um i have asked anonymous questions in
company town halls to leadership
specifically addressing i want this
leader to ask it and they have skipped
those questions for lack of time or just
blown past it so uh kudos to you for
working where you work
thank you all for for jumping in there
too
and thank you to whoever asked that
question that was an awesome question
um i see
there was also a question in the chat
that
i'll read out loud and feel free to jump
in if you want to add any more contacts
but it was i recently joined a data
science group of younger folks who use r
and their degrees are in math and
science while mine is engineering
so i offer a lot to them but i'm way
behind in programming which i never
formally learned
any suggestions on where to start
uh yes me i'll just take one quick
minute uh mainly here because i want to
learn r uh my supervisor is excellent
where i've joined and he likes all i
brought a lot of fresh ideas to him and
messy excel sheets and he says learn r
you said go online find some stuff and i
found myself here so just um
mainly just wanted to say that's why i'm
here and there may be some other people
a bit the same and kind of wondering you
know i found you guys here through
linkedin i think and you know two or
three other websites and
kind of just going and it's going very
well but i just i figured there may be
some other people and some tips and
stuff so i that's pretty much it and um
just wanted to throw that out there and
i welcome any direction and so far it's
been going very well i've been
integrating data sets aligning stuff
with our plotting stuff very
slowly but progressively and that's
mainly it yep
well i first want to just say welcome
ben welcome to the data science hangout
i'm glad you found us
i know that there's probably a bunch of
resources that people on the call can
recommend if you want to put some in the
chat too but i'm curious teresa if
there's specific ones
that you have in mind
um i'm gonna i think this is a good
crowdsourcing question
because my um
i i'm self-taught and you know and had
classes on our so i'm probably not the
best best one to ask
and i also noticed the marathon in the
background so you may have to connect
with frank on here too
yeah a bunch of them yeah yeah that's
awesome
i know a few people are putting things
in the chat too which um are for data
science there's also a great online
learning community associated with that
book
and
it's a slack channel that you can join
and i'm going to put that one in the
chat too but i think that's a great
place to start too and it's a great
community of people learning there
um i see someone's hands raised brian do
you have any recommendations
yeah so i was putting in the chat um
many moons ago i was actually obsolete
and needed to learn a new language
um
and so i picked up r and i was
between jobs at the moment
um so i crammed the coursera curriculum
down at about three months it was like
nine classes
um but one of the things that i found
useful
was rather than to use their data sets
i had old data sets from other projects
in excel that i used um
to get better at doing stuff like time
series and things that i was really
interested in but
it's a good program um
and the other place that i do probably
not almost 100 of my learning now it's
on you to me
and the just find a well-rated course um
half hour day it's what i always say
you'll be done in a few weeks and you
will have gone miles
without even realizing it
and i mean that's part of my daily
routine now
half hour you to me in the morning and
several hours every every night
but you'll get
you'll get there fast
and my new group that i'm working in um
fortunately being new they're trying to
find things for me to do so i have the
luxury of a lot of time and they've been
letting me do billable work with
learning r understanding it takes me a
bit of time so i've been able to do new
fresh things with r which i won't have
forever and it's a good month or so to
really tap into that um you know a lot
of us face a lot of billable things and
stuff and
the previous group i was in really just
didn't
see much light in this but that's um but
yeah moving forward i'm just excited
yeah and i agree some of the old stuff
is good because you know how it is but i
i'm at a point now where i'm given a
couple of tasks i'm actually doing them
in our and it's a research thing that
can take some time so it's been it's
been good and i've been you know going
through tutorials and finding things but
again some of these suggestions i'll
definitely document these and i
appreciate everybody and all the
suggestions
so yeah
your biggest friend
that you'll find is our markdown
um
because when you start publishing in our
markdown and it's reproducible
and it's professional looking
even if it's you know two slides or
three slides
going to go miles for you um
and it i mean at the end of the day is
the role of data science is to present
ideas to people
and our markdown is the old to me in my
opinion it's the ultimate tool to do it
and as some people know i'm a big python
person
and i use tons of reticulate and i
present most of my python in our
markdown too
so
it'll be your best friend down the road
thanks brian
and there's so many great
recommendations in the chat too so i'm
going to put my linkedin here if you
wanted to connect with me i'll send
those
to you as well
and apologize i didn't catch your name i
thought it was a judge
aaron like the baseball player only yeah
not the baseball player but yeah nice
nice to meet you i run marathons i don't
play baseball but yep
yeah connect with me there and i and i
can send you all these too um brian sam
i saw you had your hand raised earlier
too if you wanted to jump in
yeah um yeah apparently just duprised in
this call so
so no way brian so
three brian's actually got three brian's
okay
all right well i meant to answer aaron
so um for me i learned r by myself
before my master program um so
um from my
background most of the time i work on
the spreadsheet excel so um
i found a book like
excel user r for excel user so it's kind
of like helped me to transition get like
um get started to like heart programming
so it helps me to you know
this the book kind of like the way
written is speak from an excel point of
view and then translate to r and then
that's how i got into it and then
start picking up um
other resources like watching youtube
tutorial tutorials and r and then as
well of you know taking some courses
online
and that helped me to prep up um you
know be familiar with programming in
general and then help me transition to
python where you know use both r and
python from a masters and then now i'm
working pretty much
python right now with my current job but
r i'm still
still my first language so which i
really enjoyed the most but yeah
definitely like
aaron like right now you say your
spreadsheet or something um that's my
recommendation like
working from
excel to
our python is like a really great way
you know moving forward
yep
thank you thank you brian mike i saw you
had your hand raised too
yeah thanks that so
i would echo
learning in our markdown is a fantastic
way to to do it because
you
in many of the learning resources you'll
see there's a chunk of text that says
what is it we're going to try and do
then a block of code that says now i'm
going to do it
but the good thing is that if you work
through that at the end of the day you
hit the net button
and you will check that all your code is
still working all the way through top to
bottom and you get a pdf of what you've
just worked on or an html or whatever
format you like so in that sense it's
really nice to just kind of capture okay
today i learned this thing
start to finish
capture it move on to the next thing but
as other people have said as you're
learning that
you can then figure out that well
instead of it all being our chunks i can
have sql chunk i could have a python
chunk and you can start swapping in
these different uh really cool little
bits that that can go into a markdown
um the other thing i should say
the from the our studio conferences
like from probably two years ago and and
back from there
there are workshops where all the
workshop materials including the the
master the tidy verse course
they're all available online on github
in the our studio education github
so you can actually go to github
download
all of that content with the slides the
exercises everything you need is going
to be there
and start working from that point um
those are just it's amazing the
resources that are available on there
last tip sorry
no i love it it is is
the the i'm a certified tidy verse
trainer so i'm slightly passionate about
this
if you can start with learning um as
people have said you know creating
market markdown documents so that you've
then got something nice to share with
your clients and say or your customers
and say hey you know here's your answer
and here's why the other thing is
learning something like visualization
right so you get your data in from
wherever the source is
visualize it with ggplot2 or some other
method
because the the trainings is saying is
really great if you can get productive
things out really quickly
right because that then keeps the
motivation up and it says well you know
okay i'll learn about this other topic
later but right now i can make some cool
graphs
so start with something that will
actually you could then deliver on to
your customers clients
start there and then gradually kind of
go into more complex data types or
things like that
thank you yeah it's mostly internal
stuff i'm doing but eventually do you
want to publish this so it's mostly a
lot of back and forth rapid fire between
my co-workers and then getting things
that make sense and then going with that
and you know i was told either use our
python take your pick i kind of went
this way but i wasn't really fed here
and um yeah thank you that was helpful
yep my the other thing sorry rachel the
other thing i'm really passionate about
is everyone should be using our markdown
every time right if you write more code
than comments
write more comments and use our markdown
if you write more comments than code
put it in our markdown
um
i find that writing in our markdown is
the aid memoir for later for me in six
months when i come back to it and i was
thinking what the heck was i thinking
when i programmed this if you've got it
in an r markdown you've got that kind of
story
board that says this is what i was doing
this is why i was doing it here's where
i got the data who sent it to me when
did they send it where did i store it
so it's just it's a godsend later on
when you you try to reconstruct what you
were doing
i like what libby said to or even me
tomorrow when i can't remember why i
coded that i feel like that too
um teresa i know an hour just went by
super fast so i just wanted to see if
you had a few more minutes to
to stay on with us i yeah i don't
actually um i do have to run but um
this has been an awful lot of fun and
it's been a pleasure
and um please look me up on linkedin
look at my post take a look at those
requisitions it's a very exciting time
to be part of the space industry um
and i'm happy to connect
thank you thank you so much theresa for
hanging out with us and sharing all your
insights i'm sorry we kept you over a
little bit not a problem
thank you for saying we can all come
follow up on linkedin as well
i'm happy to to stay on if anybody wants
to stay and hang out
and continue the conversation around
learning resources too
but thank you so much teresa
thank you
thanks everybody give us the day
javier i know you were just about to add
some more resources as well
i didn't realize what time it was
um
just
it sounds like aaron has sort of
you know management
approval and go-ahead to do this which i
think is great um
i was
mainly going to
tell him that maybe having a
conversation with
his leadership and maybe some of the you
know business partners that are used to
sort of receiving deliverables in excel
format that it might be worth having a
conversation
which i did at my last job
just saying hey we're in the process of
transitioning a lot of our modeling
workflows from excel to
um
something with our programming language
or python and so if you could give you
know be patient with us
uh these deliverables will take a little
bit longer to get to you at first but
then you know you'll start seeing much
faster like rapid delivery of these
things
um
that really helped
you know my team because we would get
these
sort of ad hoc requests that the
requester thought would take like 30
minutes
but
even in excel it would take much longer
than that let alone starting a whole new
sort of process and workflow of doing it
programmatically so anyway
yeah
yeah that's very much appreciated a lot
of what i face is um billable time and
um not so much turnaround there's
there's two things with clients is
turnaround time when did they get their
stuff back and how much time do we build
um i mainly focus on my less billable
time and again where i was working a
year ago
they it wasn't so much a big deal but
where i am now they look at that as a
valuable thing and even if it takes a
little longer now and twice as fast next
time it really seems that they're
interested in that and that's i'm very
excited about that
um so it's mostly just internal internal
time and i understand there's two things
and all that um but i'll keep that in
mind you know mostly our clients want to
see good results you know um as promised
however that was promised and that's
really beyond me i'm not a salesperson
so i don't do that so much you know they
check with me and say how long does it
take you to do this i'm like well
there's you know i can get it done by
this time in this many hours there's
sort of two things that i did juggle
with
and um i really faced both of those so
you hit one of them and i have a bit
more focus on the other but there are
the two of them and i don't know if
maybe others have the same thing too or
not you know because you know a lot of
this running excel stuff there's been
times months ago where i'd run excel and
go to bed and come back and excel still
computing you know i have a 64-bit
computer it's super fast and
i have excel files that are over two
gigs in size and i was like this is
silly you know so
so yeah thank you
i met i see you had your hand raised too
if you want to jump in
or maybe you accidentally have your hand
raised
oh i think you might be just muted
there you go
i would like to answer your
question from my side
is that i'm a big fan of
project baseband and i understand that
you're an engineer so you have tasks so
so uh my two steps would be to really
solve problems and
i'm having a little bit of difficulty
hearing you okay
any better right now yes that's perfect
okay
uh so like
accomplishing stuff was the thing that
really taught me the best and
i'm a big fan of project-based learning
so
accomplishing tasks is the best teacher
in my humble opinion and that's where i
would
in my company i always have people
working for me who would like to take
classes on udemy first learn the
language and then maybe try to solve
problems but i always stop them and
times have changed and i push them into
the challenge especially if there are
resources around that
you can make use of that will be my
my style
definitely thank you for all these all
these suggestions too i i see
um
auntie you said oh you don't have to go
yet i still want to say
okay
thank you i thought you were adding uh
adding a tip there too but thank you so
much for joining are there other
suggestions that people have on the call
hey larry
oh i saw your hand was raised for a
second there you go
uh one trick that i do is uh
i i lock victories and failures and post
them for everybody to see
and it holds me temple and then whenever
i get a failure
i get quite the response from the r
community
so you could try that too
for sure i would say there's no shortage
of people that are willing to help and
want to share their experience too which
which is really helpful
um i know some of the other questions
that we didn't get to were specifically
for teresa
more around like
working in in space and her thoughts on
that but um if there are other questions
that we didn't address that you want to
post to the broader group feel free to
to jump in into
i just love
it from leadership sorry kate i see you
had a question um well it's more of a
statement i just wanted to say like
thank you all for the discussion today
about i don't know introvertedness and
everything it was
interesting and encouraging as somebody
who doesn't speak up all the time
thank you so much kate
yeah i i love that part of the
conversation too and i was thinking
maybe we
should take all the tips that were
shared in the chat and in
and live and put those all together to
share with everyone too
i was able to control all copy but yeah
it's nice to have it in there for yeah
brian i think you were about to add
something too yeah i love how you
obvious comment
the worst conversation you're going to
have is when it starts this will only
take you
20 minutes
and
i don't care what tool they think
they're using you know when i when when
that phrase comes out of the person's
mouth i'm like oh here we go
it just resonated thanks for bringing
that up bobby
yeah i think thank you all for for
jumping in i
this is seriously one of my favorite
parts of the week and it's so fun to see
people coming back week after week and
finally like getting to know each other
too i just want to say thank you all so
much for for joining
and looking forward to hopefully seeing
you next week too
but have a great rest of the day
everyone
you